hostiles have the hard
point hard point locked
down be advised hostile UAV
incoming hardpoint lost
hard point is
out UAV
ready hard point
contested hardpoint lost hostiles have
captured the
hardpoint
eliminate Hardo is
ours Hardo lost hostile UAV
Spott
hard point identified hardpoint is ours
hardpoint
lost
wasted shot
out time's running out finish
this hard point locked
down hardpoint
lost be advised hostile UAV
incoming securing
C losing
Alpha
UAV security
Charli all flag secured maintain current
posture Mother Ship
inbound flag carrier down UAV ready for
deployment enemy flag acquired proper
requesting eyes on enemy
positions hostiles have taken our
flag
recharge package
on our flight is
secur
capture the enemy
flag enemy flag
acquired